powell had a little get together now for
reddit this afternoon
um they said that lynn wood
pacing across the stage said we're not
going to vote for this machine i'm not
using machines to vote
and you know we shouldn't go out and
vote from senator leffler and perdue and
i find it interesting that somebody
who's had a democrat voting record since
2004 is out there telling republicans
not to vote in an election
we encourage all voters to vote in an
election democrat republican independent
green socialist you know
libertarian whatever party you want to
be go out and exercise your votes
you're right as an american another
thing that um sydney powell then said
was the algorithm absolutely switch
votes in georgia
not true we did again i'm going to
remind everybody we did a hand audit
that human beings
did no machines were used and in fact
somebody asked glenn wood and sydney
powell
the hand on it said this how how do you
know how can your algorithm thing have
worked
and they said no no that wasn't a hand
audit they used the machines to count
those they
lied to the people who are believing
there's face
it's this kind of lying and this kind of
rhetoric that is continuing
to inflame passions on the ground
unnecessarily
and it's wrong so with that i want to go
and just
take any questions you all might have
yes sir
i mean what happens is they they put
them into the election night reporting
system
we look them over then we upload them so
when we launch this
in about probably 20 minutes or so
you'll see those 132 or so will be on
there immediately
and then as the counties continue to
upload them throughout the evening
we will continue to upload them um we'll
probably send our employee who does that
home
he had a very long night night last
night
and i hate this is gonna seem like i'm
just piling on at this point
he couldn't get out of here until 12 15
because for the special election
district five
fulton county had to send two employees
out to find two memory cards they left
behind
so again we see the same kind of issues
that come out on those things and it
caused our staff to have to stay late
so we're trying to let him go home get
some rest and do some work remotely to
do those final uploads
so it should be through the night and if
there's a couple of counties to lag
if they're tired the work's getting done
it'll be done by tomorrow they're all
going to meet the deadlines of
recertifying by friday
and then the state will meet its
deadline of reform recertifying by
friday afternoon
then the governor will do the
ascertainment and send the paperwork
back up to dc
here's the thing i can't make the case
there's there's one particular counter
that's always last i don't have to say
it you know i don't have to say it
but there's always going to be one so
what else we got
i do not have that number it will be
kept at the county level i don't think
we have a generalized report for that
but it's probably a good thing we'll
probably have to get
what else we got all right these things
are getting shorter and shorter i like
it
but i appreciate it sorry i didn't have
as much bombass today but i'm kind of
happy i didn't have to
you know justin from wsb asked about
that earlier and
frankly i dropped off my radar screen
because i'm on the legal team again i'll
say the same
same thing as i said before we follow
the law the federal state laws on the
when we do the list maintenance that is
necessary to keep the voter rolls clean
and protect the sanctity and security of
the vote thanks
you